- Can you hear me okay?
Perfect. All right, wonderful.
So the agenda for this, gonna speak for,
I'm so privileged to have one
of our valuable customers,
Equifax, with me today,
to share their experiences
as well on the multi-cloud.
But I'm gonna spend like
seven, eight minutes talking
through some general overview topics
and then hand it over to Avinash and then,
we try to leave four or five minutes
if you have any questions
to go through that.
All right, my name is Kambiz Aghili,
I'm vice president of product for CI
in charge of multi-cloud.
So thrilled to be here with you.
A couple things wanted to
talk about to establish
what multi-cloud is.
Oracle has been a, you know,
best in class database,
(indistinct) database technology
for the past 40 years.
Any of the eight or nine
out of 10 verticals,
customers within each
vertical you look at,
they're utilizing Oracle
one way or another.
And Oracle has always been
available on premises across
different deployment models.
And this is the first time
that we're bringing the Oracle end to end,
the Exadata technology
and an entire database services
and all the surrounding elements
of the Oracle technology
natively available
through AWS data center, right?
So Oracle is in all
clouds, including now AWS
and Azure and GCP, natively
operating from data center,
operating from the Exadata hardware.
And we'll talk about some
of the things that are
so unique about it as opposed
to operating just on a commodity hardware.
So we've been working really,
really hard since last year
to continue to innovate on
behalf of the customers.
If I were to classify three
categories of innovations
that we work really hard on, you know,
on the customer requirements to deliver,
they're threefold.
One is on simplifying the management
and operations of the database.
So customers now they have,
you know, access to tools
to automate the database
infrastructure as code.
They can utilize API, CLI, SDKs,
cloud formation as well as Terraform.
So simplifies end to end of their journey.
Two, now we do offer customers
the full automated data protection
in near real time,
whereas they can utilize
autonomous recovery service
that was never ever available
through a third party
cloud natively operating
on our hardware before.
Third is security.
We understood that it's
really critical for customers
to be able to not only
use our Oracle technology
in terms of a database
and all the underlying services we offer,
but also to be able to integrate very well
with the AWS's best in
class also cloud and AI
as well as the, you know,
operational services and around it.
So for instance, from a security
perspective, now we offer
as of last week integration
with the AWS Key Management, KMS.
And this is really fantastic
because customers who love to use KMS,
they're able to utilize that on Oracle
operating natively on OCI
from the AWS data center
like never before.
And on that angle, they're
also able to continue
to use other services around
security, including OCI Vault
and Oracle Key Vault and TDE.
So when you look at the
multi-cloud is basically operating
all the Oracle database services
and services around it,
operating on native Oracle
hardware infrastructure
from the AWS data center, with
the native interoperability
of the Oracle technology
alongside all the AWS services
that customers would love to use, right?
So there's a ton of integration
that we have put in place
in terms of you want to use,
you saw the prior presentation as well,
that you want to use,
you know, AWS's Bedrock,
you want to use agentic application.
So this gives you ability
to combine the data from the
Oracle data, Oracle workloads,
and Oracle Exadata,
and then you know, autonomous AI database
with the AWS services
and AI capabilities natively
integrated with one another.
So when you're building and
modernizing new applications
that need to utilize AI
or need to utilize the
best of breed of, you know,
kind of both technologies,
this is for the first time,
it's available.
And the third piece in
addition to integration
is just like making sure
that we have federated or otherwise,
having all these surrounding services
around operational governance and security
and data protection to be
also available natively
and integrated with AWS.
As the two key players there
that have never ever been done before.
Exadata has been the best
in class hardware technology
for running database services.
It's the unique technology that allows you
from an enterprise class set of workloads
to have zero RTO, RPO within
region across multiple AZs,
as well as getting to, you know,
near zero asynchronous data guard
and billing active configurations
across the regions.
So all of these are now available
natively to AWS customers
that would love to utilize both
services across AWS regions
that are operating Oracle workloads.
Again, it's a full
end-to-end feature parity,
performance parity, MA your
architecture of the Oracle,
that technology customer
have used for 30, 40 years,
available natively to them from
AWS under Oracle database
at AWS specifically.
Not to confuse with the other services
that are operating on the
commodity hardware and AWS,
but compliments them for the most part.
We have low latency networks built out
into the configuration,
whereas customers who
were running applications
and the database tiers
independently of one another,
separately than one another,
these are now operating
from the same data center
with microsecond latency in between.
So as you're thinking about
agentic AI applications,
modernizing your applications
or building new configurations over time,
that latency plays a
very, very unique play
into the horizon going forward.
Seamless experience, customers
will have the same experience
going to the AWS marketplace
as they do with any
of the other first class AWS services.
They can utilize the AWS PPA
and all the other capabilities and
financial means that are
available to them to procure
and pay for Oracle services
operating natively from AWS.
And then as I indicated,
connecting these services
to one another is built in natively
into what we have offered.
So I'm gonna stop there,
you know, for a second,
hand over to Avinash from Equifax
to share their experience.
One thing I wanted to share is
that we launched last year GA,
so this is an enterprise class service
with hundreds and hundreds
of customers already on it.
We are available in US east, west,
two AZs, multiple AZs each.
We are launching three more regions
with multiple AZs at the end of this month
where 20 more regions are
aligned with a, you know,
next nine to 10 months to
go live and GA accordingly.
So this is a service
gonna be available in,
and around the world,
everywhere customers need it.
Avinash, take it over. Thank you.
- Hello everybody.
Are you able to hear me? Cool.
So I will talk a little bit about Equifax.
I think most of the people in US at least
that are using Equifax as one
of the major credit bureau,
we are not just a credit bureau company,
we are a data company.
We have all the consumer data and all.
So why Equifax basically.
So, I mean it's a very loaded slide.
I cannot go everything based
on the given time I have.
So I will just talk a little bit about
how Equifax is using AI and then AWS
and all other cloud provider services.
So Equifax built its own cloud internally,
we call it data fabric layer,
and we harness all the
data of the consumer
and provide the insights of the data
to the consumer for their benefits.
So we are mainly providing
three major services like
employer workforce solution,
US information system solutions,
which is like mortgage services and all.
If you go for any mortgage and all that,
any bank or any lenders,
they use our Equifax services
for all the verifications.
Employment verification.
If you join any company
and you know, a company needs to
do the verification and all,
they use our services.
So Equifax is a lot of services.
These are the major services
which most of the people are aware of.
So I was just talking about that.
So how that all the data that Equifax use
and provide that by
maintaining that Equifax cloud.
So we have that internal
Equifax own design
for our cloud stuffs to
provide the real time insight,
multi-data asset at scale,
improved speed and performance.
Because when that, you need or any B2B,
our customer need any data,
their performance and speed
is very important, right?
So there are a lot to talk,
I mean you guys can have
that access to the slide,
you can read through that.
Any question always
ready to answer further.
So we are using autonomous database at AWS
because we have that.
So I support basically
all the enterprise data
and financial systems.
So financial systems consist
of the billing system,
which is very highly
OATP database we need.
So currently we are having
like billions of users' records
come to our system
and then we have to process,
we have the three major billing cycles.
Before the billing cycle,
we have to rate all the data,
we have to build the data,
create the billing data,
create the invoice,
and ship the invoice.
So it's a very, very always
time constraint related, right?
We need a very high performance
system to perform that,
otherwise that we have a revenue loss.
If that we don't ship the invoices on time
that we will have a revenue loss.
And also that the data
that we cannot, you know,
immediately remove the
data from the system.
So we need a high storage data.
So I mean like this is like a
high level architecture that
how the data comes to the system
and how we process and all that.
Certain points are there
that high volume process,
users processing,
dynamic order management and all that.
So what are the major key benefits
that we are getting using ADB?
So currently that we are
using RDS, RDS Oracle,
definitely very good service.
We have been using since seven years RDS
for BRM system.
Over the seven year period time
that our database is grown like anything.
So we are at the world
of around 64 terabyte.
Good news that yesterday it was announced
that we are having the 256
terabyte version of RDS.
But the reason of moving to ADB is,
basically it is sitting in AWS,
using all the infrastructure of ADB,
ODB which is sitting in AWS.
So as Kambiz mentioned that,
I mean Exadata is sitting
on the AWS data center.
So my all the application
are sitting in the AWS.
So it's a seamless no latency, no issues,
even if that we want to use
that Exadata service in OCI,
we will have to deal with the
latency between AWS and OCI.
So this is like kind of
a best of the both world.
So I mean like major is optimized
performance and throughput.
If you see that we are like
a very highly OATP systems,
we have to, as I
mentioned, that we have to
do the users on time,
create the billing and
invoices and ship the invoices.
So we need very, very
high performance system,
which underline Exadata is
definitely going to help us.
Scalable storage and data visibility.
So I mean like Exadata provides
that petabytes of storage so we don't have
to worry about storage constraint,
which other database services we have.
For an example that,
currently to manage RDS,
we are having 64 terabyte limitation.
So we have to every quarter purge the data
and then archive the data
whatever we are purging,
because the billing data,
we cannot just purge it.
So we have to maintain a lot of archives
because of that process and limitation.
So with Exadata
and the petabytes of the storage capacity,
we don't need to worry about.
And also once that our data grows
in size, Exadata performance will help
to, you know, navigate that data.
If any other service we are
taking for Oracle databases
to run like on-prem
or whatever, we have to do a lot
of maintenance activities for that.
So that is one of the best
benefit we are getting
using this service.
As I mentioned that (indistinct)
unified cloud workload,
because it is sitting with AWS,
we have a lot of AWS
services we are using.
So it is seamless integration,
is another key benefit
we are using through ADB.
We also have one important
part is that 23 AI
and 26 AI, Oracle AI was
that 26 AI was announced.
So by moving to this that we
are making our data AI ready.
So application has made constant
because we are using
Oracle billing system,
which is (indistinct) product,
it may lag on their
roadmap for AI enablement.
But what we could do by moving to ADB,
we are making our data AI ready
so we can have our own AI
solution sitting on ADB
using Apex and all that which
is available as part of ADB.
So these are the major benefits.
Due to time constraint,
I will just pass it to Kambiz.
- Yeah, yeah, sure.
Hey, thank you Avinash,
really appreciate it.
All right, so there are a bunch of places
you can go to learn more.
Just simply search for Oracle multi-cloud,
search for multi-cloud on Google
or some of the links here that
I'm sure you can remember.
But the video recording will be available
on the AWS website in a couple weeks
and I wanted to dedicate
between Avinash and I,
four, five, six minutes for
any questions you might have.
So there's a microphone out
there if you have questions.
We are here at your disposal.
(attendees chatting)
- [Avinash] I should have taken more time.
- [Kambiz] All right, give
you back the two minutes.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it, thanks
for being here. Bye.
- Thank you, Kambiz.
- Thank you.